[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen es ist eine feine
Austarierung von deren Erfolg am Ende
das Funktionieren unserer Gemeinschaft
in Deutschland abhängt die Balance
zwischen sozialen Hilfen und einem
soliden Umfeld für die die Arbeiten
zwischen Sozialstaat und
wirtschaftlichen Chancen es ist im
Grunde die alte Regel arbeit muss sich
lohnen der Standard Slogan in der
Politik wer arbeitet muss mehr haben als
der der nicht arbeitet um exakt diese
Balance ist jetzt ein Streit entbrannt
er entzündet sich an den Kosten für die
Kinder Grundsicherung aber vor allem an
der deutlichen Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes
früher Hartz IV die ist zwar keine
spontane politische
Ermessensentscheidung sondern beruht auf
gesetzlich festgelegten Mechanismen aber
dennoch zwölf Prozent plus das lässt
aufhorchen Britta Buchholz
die Ampel wollte gerade ihren
Schlingerkurs verlassen geräuschloser
sollte regiert werden da kommt die grüne
Fraktionsspitze mächtig in Fahrt auf
einem Rummel im bayerischen Nürnberger
gehen sie auf Wahlkampftour bei einer
Klausur fordern Sie mehr Geld für die
kriselnde Wirtschaft ein
subventionierten industriestrompreis und
noch mehr
wir haben uns noch einiges vorgenommen
was die Rente angeht die Absicherung des
Renteneintritts Rentenniveaus plus die
aktienrente auch das sind Vorhaben die
wir noch gemeinsam als Ampel haben im
sozialen Bereich das heißt nicht ein
Bereich ist abgeschlossen sondern
Probleme werden gelöst doch das Problem
der Ampel es fehlt das Geld die
Familienministerin nannte heute erstmal
zahlen demnach könnte die Kinder
Grundsicherung je nach Alter des Kindes
zwischen 530 und 636 Euro pro Monat
kosten der Arbeitsminister Heil setzt
für 5,5 Millionen Menschen mehr
Bürgergeld rund 12% durch alleinstehende
erhalten dann ab 20 24
563 € pro Monat mit Partnern zusammen
lebende Erwachsene erhalten 5006 Euro
kann sich Deutschland das leisten die
FDP fordert einen Sozialreform Stopp
für uns als FDP ist klar es geht jetzt
ums erwirtschaften und um Entlastung
nicht um die Ausweitung des Sozialstaats
im Kern geht es darum wie Deutschland
mit denen umgeht die nicht arbeiten denn
im steigenden Bürgergeld lauert eine
Gefahr eine Studie des Kieler Instituts
für Weltwirtschaft vergleicht das
Einkommen von Erwachsenen mit
Mindestlohn Verdienst und solche mit
Leistungen aus dem Bürgergeld sie warnen
vor einem geringen Lohnabstand gerade
bei mehreren Kindern es ist so dass
Haushalte wo eine Person Vollzeit
zumindestlohn arbeitet in vielen Fällen
trotz Beantragung von Kinder und
Wohngeld netto weniger haben als
Bürgergeld Empfänger arbeitende müssen
dann oftmals aufstocken zum Amt trotz
Arbeit ich finde es auch nicht
gerechtfertigt wenn ein vollarbeitende
Haushalt noch sozial oder Bürgergeld
beantragen muss und die Anzahl der
Haushalte die davon betroffen sind wird
durch die Steigerung des Bürgergeldes
natürlich erhöht werden
die Union die dem Bürgergeld im
Bundestag zugestimmt hat warnt nun gar
vor weniger Leistungsbereitschaft die
hohen Transferleistungen auch die der
bundessozialminister jetzt angekündigt
hat für das Bürgergeld im nächsten Jahr
werden weiter dazu führen dass viele
private Haushalte sich genau ausrechnen
ob sich überhaupt noch lohnt zu arbeiten
wenn die Transferleistungen höher sind
als die
Löhne nach Abzug von Steuern und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen hier stimmt
die ganze Statik unseres Sozialstaates
nicht mehr Menschen leben in Armut weil
sie zu wenig Geld haben und natürlich
brauchen Sie dafür auch höhere
staatliche Unterstützungen einig ist man
sich Kindern und Familien soll es besser
gehen in Deutschland das Bürgergeld ist
ein Baustein dafür einer mit brisants
so jetzt der Mann der Deutschlands
teuerstes Ministerium führt mit dem
höchsten Etat er verwaltet den
Sozialstaat der Arbeits- und
Sozialminister Hubertus Heil guten Abend
Herr Heil guten Abend Herr Sievers grüße
sie sind wir noch im Gleichgewicht
zwischen dem Staat der Bedürftige
sozialabfedert und dem der die
arbeitende Bevölkerung unterstützt ja
denn klar ist Arbeit muss ein
Unterschied machen ist eine Frage des
Respekts und der Leistungsgerechtigkeit
deshalb haben wir ja den Mindestlohn
erhöht wir haben
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und Steuern
für Geringverdiener gesenkt im das
Kindergeld erhöht und auch das
wohngeldverarbeitende Menschen das ist
notwendig damit Arbeit sich lohnt und
das andere ist ganz klar dass wir ein
Existenzminimum für die absichern müssen
die sich nicht selbst helfen können Sie
verstehen dass jemand mit wenig
Einkommen aber harte Arbeit der oder die
jeden morgen früh aufstehen muss sich
die Augen reibt bei 12% Plus beim
Bürgergeld ich kann die Diskussion
verstehen aber man muss das klar auch
sortieren Arbeit muss ein Unterschied
machen
auch da drauf verwiesen das ist noch ein
Lohnabstand geben muss aber klar ist
auch dass es eine existenzminum gibt das
ist eine Frage unseres Grundgesetzes ist
Verfassungsgericht hat entschieden dass
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen oder
ohne Einkommen in ihrer Existenz
gesichert sein müssen und ich will auch
darauf verweisen dass im Bürgergeld ja
auch Menschen sind die gar nicht
langzeitarbeitslos sind sondern die
Arbeiten und die ergänzende
Grundsicherung brauchen über die rund zu
kommen zum Beispiel Alleinerziehende die
niedrige Löhne haben also wer
Lohnabstand will und das will ich der
muss für bessere Löhne kämpfen das haben
wir mit dem Mindestlohn gezeigt 22% plus
war das im letzten Jahr auf die 12 € und
wir werden weitergehen wir werden dafür
sorgen dass es wieder mehr Tarifverträge
gibt in Deutschland denn da wo
Tarifverträge sind sind die Löhne und
Arbeitsbedingungen besser sie haben
jetzt schon zweimal gesagt das muss ein
Lohnabstand geben arbeit muss sich
lohnen das versucht das System ja auch
mit vielen Details und sehr kompliziert
tatsächlich hinzubekommen Stichwort auf
Stocker haben sie auch gerade kurz
angesprochen aber muss dieser
Unterschied nicht für alle Bürgerinnen
und Bürger viel klarer auf der Hand
liegen der Muskel auf der Hand liegen
aber die Stellschraube ist nicht
willkürlich das Existenzminimum zu
beschneiden und die Tatsache dass es
jetzt deutliche Steigerung beim
Bürgergeld gibt ist ja der Tatsache
geschuldet dass wir eine kräftige
Inflation hatten der Schlüssel zum
Lohnabstand sind bessere Lohn- und
Arbeitsbedingungen dafür kämpfe ich als
Arbeitsminister das haben wir bewiesen
und das werden wir auch weiter das
Interessante ist ja sie haben die
Inflation die die schlägt dann sofort
aufs Bürgergeld durch wird also sofort
vom Bürgergeld gespiegelt das haben sie
geändert tatsächlich das ist ja sehr
erfreulich für die die Bürger Geld
beziehen aber für alle anderen die
merken ja dass sie unter der Inflation
echt sind aber eben ihre Löhne nicht in
dem Maße steigen also erstens haben alle
in dieser Gesellschaft und unter der
Inflation gelitten und viele tun es noch
und klar ist auch dass das dazu geführt
hat dass die am meisten gelitten haben
die am wenigsten haben und ich halt
nichts davon Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen gegen bedürftige Menschen
auszuspielen wie Friedrich Merz das
gerade tut wir müssen beide im Blick
haben die gesamte Gesellschaft und klar
ist auch und das ist die gute Nachricht
in all der schwierigen Zeit dass im
ersten Hälfte dieses Jahres Gott sei
Dank endlich die Tarifabschlüsse und
dazu haben wir als Staat auch einen
Beitrag gelassen und ihr
Entlastungsmaßnahmen dazu geführt haben
dass das erste Mal Gott sei Dank wieder
auch Lohnsteigerung da waren die über
der Inflationsrate waren aber noch mal
wir müssen Menschen und hilfsbedürftige
Menschen absichern das ist keine Idee
von mir das ergibt sich aus unserem
Grundgesetz und deshalb kann man nicht
willkürlich das Existenzminimum
unterrechnen reden wir mal über das ganz
große Bild manche Superreiche haben sich
längst verabschiedet die Steuern
irgendwo anders dann gibt es Empfänger
von Transferleistungen über die haben
wir schon geredet und in der Mitte dann
eine Gruppe die alles zahlt und das
Gefühl hat bei ihr bleibt zu wenig
hängen sie sind ja als Sozialminister
doch auch für das soziale Gleichgewicht
in diesem Land zuständig ich bin
Arbeits- und Sozialminister und deshalb
ist es für mich wichtig mich für die
arbeitenden Menschen in diesem Land
einzusetzen das tue ich seit Jahren das
tue ich auch weiterhin damit wir
gerechtere Lohnentwicklung haben da ist
viel auseinandergegangen im letzten Jahr
sie haben das beschrieben vor allen
Dingen dadurch dass nur noch 22% der
beschäftigtenden Dach eines
Tarifvertrages ist und noch mal wo
Tarife sind sind die Lohn- und
gehaltsbedingungen besser deshalb werden
wir zum Beispiel ein Gesetz vorlegen
dass die öffentlichen Aufträge des
Bundes nur noch an die Unternehmen gehen
die nach Tarif bezahlen ist eine Frage
der Fairness also wir müssen die Balance
im Land halten aber wir müssen die
gesamte Gesellschaft im Blick halten das
nützt ja nicht gesellschaftliche Gruppen
gegeneinander auszuspielen gerade bei
größeren Familien können sich
Sozialleistungen summieren die
Familienministerin spricht heute von bis
zu
636 Euro Kinder Grundsicherung in
Zukunft pro Kind und Monat wie erhalten
Sie denn da den Anreiz zu arbeiten es
ist tatsächlich so dass mit der
Kindergrundsicherung ist dass wir ein
Abstand haben es gibt einen
garantiebetracht der steht Leben zur
Verfügung und einkommensabhängige
Zuschläge und das ja auch die Idee des
Kunden kinderzuschlages und ich will
noch mal sagen es gibt auch Wohngeld für
arbeitende Menschen weil Mietkosten
beispielsweise in Ballungszentren ein
großes Problem geworden sind also sie
müssen gucken dass Arbeiten Unterschied
macht das ist mir sehr sehr wichtig
nochmal eine Frage des Respekts und der
Leistungsgerechtigkeit aber wir müssen
uns auch um die kümmern die sich nicht
selbst helfen können mein Ziel ist es
aber auch dass wir mehr Menschen aus der
Bedürftigkeit rausführen und deshalb
haben wir mit dem Bürgergeld einen
Grundsatz geschaffen wir bringen
Menschen endlich in arbeiten wenn man
sich die Struktur anguckt dann ist es so
dass zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen keine
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben
deshalb setzen wir auf Qualifizierung
und auf Ausbildung damit dafür gesorgt
wird dass die Menschen im Arbeitsmarkt
dauerhaft zur Verfügung stehen ist
übrigens auch ein Beitrag zur Fachkräfte
Sicherung jetzt haben sie das ist genau
der Punkte sie jetzt gerade angesprochen
haben Arbeitslosigkeit Fachkräfte da
habe ich noch eine letzte Frage mit der
Bitte um eine kurze Antwort bitte
erhalten die Arbeitslosigkeit ist
gestiegen leicht gestiegen heute kommen
da die neuen Zahlen gleichzeitig Stöhnen
aber viele Bereiche und viele Branchen
und zwar auch solche die ungelernte
dringend brauchen dass sie niemanden
finden der den Job macht wie passt denn
das zusammen also wir haben
konjunkturell schwieriges Umfeld die
Exportnachfrage aus Chinas
zurückgegangen aber klar ist auch wir
haben immer noch eine höchsten Stande
von sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigen das ist ein Grund das jetzt
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte schon knapp sind
das ist nicht mehr die
Massenarbeitslosigkeit von vor 20 Jahren
aber wir werden uns kümmern weil das
Problem wird größer wenn wir uns nicht
kümmern mit aus- und Weiterbildung und
dafür zu sorgen dass Menschen dauerhaft
in Arbeit sind das ist die große Aufgabe
der Fachkräfte Sicherung und der stelle
ich mich sagte der Bundesarbeitsminister
Hubertus Heil herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch halten ich danke Ihnen
das Gespräch immer aus Termin Gründen
kurz vor dieser Sendung aufgezeichnet
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf
politikarbeit vor Ort in einem Land in
den die Stimmung schon mal besser war um
es vorsichtig zu sagen Frust und
Unzufriedenheit in dem Teil Deutschlands
für den er quasi offiziell zuständig ist
will der ostbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung begegnen mit
demonstrativem Optimismus wir haben
verdammt viel erreicht und es ist ein
verdammt schönes Land sagt Carsten
Schneider und ahnt wohl gleichzeitig das
selbst wenn er Recht hat das allein
nicht reicht Christian hübscher war mit
ihm unterwegs
auch mal es gibt tatsächlich Orte in
Ostdeutschland die sind selbst für den
ostbeauftragten der Bundesregierung noch
aufregend
Neuhaus Werder war ich noch nie deswegen
ist das jetzt für mich auch
Neuland
neulandost 34 Jahre nach der Wende
Schneider der Reiseleiter aus dem
Kanzleramt bringt einen Bus voller
Berliner Journalisten mit in die Lausitz
das neue aber sei nicht ohne das alte zu
verstehen meint die Autorin Grill Lemke
im sächsischen Hoyerswerda die einzige
sozialistische Planstadt in der sie
aufgewachsen ist war die kinderreichste
der DDR also erstmal werden hier viel
viel mehr Häuser gewesen da waren zwei
Schulen also meine Schule dann Schulhof
noch eine Schule Zusammenbruch Teil
Abriss der Stadt der große Wegzug sie
hatten das hier alles schon mal jetzt
sollen sie möglichst noch 8 Jahre früher
ganz raus aus der Kohle und sind
zerrissen wir sind ja schon irgendwie
Experten des Wandels und deshalb war es
auch in den ersten Jahren des
Strukturwandels wirklich manchmal
merkwürdig wenn dann Leute hierher kamen
die eigentlich dann aus München kamen
oder so und die uns erzählen wollten wie
Transformation geht weil wir wandeln uns
hier seit 30 Jahren aber natürlich gibt
es auch es gibt schon auch so eine
Müdigkeit
es gibt ein großes Trauma nach der Kohle
kommt was neues verspricht Carsten
Schneider und verweist auf etliche
Neuansiedlungen von Industrie in der
Lausitz das größte Problem aber ist
ungelöst händeringende Suche nach
Arbeitskräften und nicht der Wegzug ist
das Thema sondern der Zuzug und die
Unternehmen aber auch die Städte müssen
quasi offene arm machen und sich darum
bemühen dass Menschen zu entkommen das
ist eine ganz große Veränderung weiß ja
das den den das ganze mindset auch
ändern Schneider nimmt die
Bürgermeisterin von Spremberg in
Brandenburg ein Stück mit auf seiner
Sommertour auch von ihr hört er das
große Thema Alter
möglichst noch vor 28 soll für das
Kohlekraftwerk Schwarze Pumpe in
Spremberg endgültig Schluss sein die
Bürgermeisterin aber braucht allein 3000
neue Einwohner und hat eine dringende
Bitte anschneider Rückkehrer Prämien
werden nicht schlecht weil
die Bedingungen in der Lausitz sind
deutlich besser geworden im Internet ist
immer noch schwierig aber hier ist noch
Platz die Grundstücke sind bezahlbar
nächste Stopp Chemnitz in Sachsen das
neue Heizwerk hier soll künftig mit
Wasserstoff betrieben werden
kommt weg scheinbar müheloser
Strukturwandel dabei brodelt es
politisch die AFD macht sich die
Unsicherheit in der ganzen Region
erfolgreich zu Nutze und das
heizungsgesetz hat massiv geschadet
gerade hier im Osten Fehler den wir ähm
jetzt korrigiert haben aber an dem
Körper natürlich noch
noch ein Jahr bis zu den Landtagswahlen
in gleich drei Ostländern wie die
ausgehen daran wird man auch ihnen
messen Carsten Schneider den
ostbeauftragten
unser nächstes Thema jetzt es gibt viele
Arten von Reue Bayerns stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident hat heute die
Entschuldigung mit konditionaler Reue
gewählt die also mit dem wenn sowie in
wenn ich Gefühle verletzt habe bereue
ich das zutiefst es ist die neueste
Wendung in Hubert aiwangers Umgang mit
der Affäre um einen widerliches
Flugblatt voller Judenhass und
Verhöhnung der Opfer des Holocaust mehr
jetzt von Alexander Pohl
keine zwei Stunden nach seinem Statement
viel Applaus für Hubert Aiwanger in
einem Festzelt in Oberbayern kurz zuvor
hatte sich der freie wählerchef in einer
lange erwarteten Erklärung entschuldigt
für Fehler die er nach bekannt werden
des judenfeindlichen Flugplatz gemacht
habe ich beruhigt so tiefst wenn ich
durch mein Verhalten in Bezug auf das in
Rede stehende Pamphlet Gefühle verletzt
habe meine aufrichtige Entschuldigung
gilt zuvor dass tollen Opfern des Ines
Regimes deren Hinterbliebenen und allen
Beteiligten und der wertvollen
Erinnerungsarbeit ich betone nochmals
ich habe das beim Fleet nicht verfasst
nicht distanziere mich in jeder Form von
dem ekelhofften Inhalt am vergangenen
Wochenende berichtet die Süddeutsche
Zeitung über ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt aus den 80er Jahren das Hubert
eiwanger verfasst haben soll diesen
Vorwurf weiß der freie wählerchef zurück
allerdings räumt er ein es sei ein ein
oder mehrere Exemplare in seiner
Schultasche gefunden worden albanas
Bruder Helmut erklärt kurz darauf Autor
des Papiers zu sein auch Bayerns
Ministerpräsident Söder bringen die
Vorwürfe in Bedrängnis er verlangt
Aufklärung von seinem Koalitionspartner
Aiwanger stellt dessen Verbleib als
Wirtschaftsminister im Kabinett in Frage
Koalitionen hängen übrigens auch nicht
an einer einzigen Person in den
vergangenen Tagen immer neue
Anschuldigungen etwa von alten
Schulkameraden aiwangers der habe
judenfeindliche Witze erzählt und den
Hitlergruß gezeigt die Grünen in Bayern
bezeichnen alwangers Entschuldigung als
überfällig ausreichend war für mich
diese Erklärung nicht es bleiben noch zu
viele Fragen offen ich halte Hubert
Aiwanger für nicht mehr tragbar albanas
Zukunft in der bayerischen
Staatsregierung liegt ab heute wieder in
der Hand von CSU-Chef Söder einen
Fragenkatalog der CSU will Aiwanger
zeitnah beantworten
so und wir reden heute mit Stefan
leifert unser Mann in München guten
Abend Stefan eiwanger entschuldigt sich
also sagt aber immer noch nicht deutlich
für was eigentlich die Vorwürfe
jedenfalls weiß der zurück
ja Hubert einfacher ist seit heute Abend
auf zwei Tonspuren unterwegs auf der
einen Tonspur sendet er das Signal von
Reue Bedauern und Entschuldigung diese
Botschaft geht in Richtung CSU
Koalitionspartner und Markus Söder die
von ihm ja genau das eingefordert haben
und auf der anderen Tonspur fliegt
Hubert awanger weiterhin der Erzählung
von der Kampagne die gegen ihn geführt
wird um ihn politisch zu vernichten
diese Botschaft geht in die eigene
Partei damit will er die rein hinter
sich schließen das gelingt auch also
einfacher versucht eine Mischung
zwischen Reue auf der einen Seite
Kampfansage auf der anderen Seite das
ist ein ziemlich schmaler Grad und in
welche Situation bringt der heutige Tag
den Ministerpräsidenten der selbst
gucken muss wie er sich verhält und ob
und wir an Aiwanger festhalten kann 38
Tage vor der Wahl
für Markus Söder ist die Zwickmühle
heute noch ein bisschen vertrackter
geworden den Hubert awanger liefert
jetzt diese neue Tonlage von der Reue
die ihr eingefordert worden ist auf der
anderen Seite kommt das ganze spät es
wirkt recht pflichtschuldig und vor
allem es wird überhaupt nicht klar wofür
sich Hubert awanger eigentlich
entschuldigt also ein Beitrag zur
Aufklärung war das heute abend nicht
Stefan Seifert ZDF München vielen Dank
und weitere Nachrichten im Überblick in
einem ersten Überblick hast jetzt
Johanna und da schauen wir zunächst auf
einen verheerenden Großbrand in einem
Gebäude im südafrikanischen
Johannes bei dem mindestens 74 Menschen
getötet worden sind darunter 12 Kinder
mehr als 50 Personen wurden laut
Rettungsdienst zudem verletzt das Feuer
in dem fünfstöckigen Gebäude war in der
Nacht ausgebrochen in dem Wohnhaus
sollen hunderte Menschen illegal gelebt
haben was den Brand genau verursacht hat
ist unklar seit einem Sprecher der
Sicherheitsbehörden könnten Ihnen
möglicherweise Kerzen ausgelöst haben
vor Beginn der haushaltswoche Bundestag
hat sich die Hilfsorganisation Brot für
die Welt kritisch zu den geplanten
Etatkürzungen für die Entwicklungshilfe
und die humanitäre Hilfe geäußert
Deutschland entzieher sich damit seiner
internationalen Verantwortung erklärte
Präsidentin der entwicklungsetat soll
laut Entwurf im kommenden Jahr von knapp
12,2 Milliarden Euro auf gut 11,5
Milliarden sinken auch bei der
humanitärenhilfe sind Kürzungen
vorgesehen noch muss allerdings der
Bundestag darüber entscheiden
das Münchner Oberlandesgericht hat einen
in Deutschland lebenden russischen
Staatsbürger zu zehn Jahren Haft
verurteilt weil dieser den Mord an einem
im Exil lebenden tschetschenischen
Regierungskritiker vorbereitet haben
soll den Auftrag erhielt der Verurteilte
nach Erkenntnissen der Ermittler aus dem
Umfeld des tschetschenischen Machthabers
kadirov das Gericht saß als erwiesen an
dass er sich bereits eine Schusswaffe
und Munition beschafft hatte
der frühere US-Präsident Trump hat nach
einer Anklage im Bundesstaat Georgia auf
nicht schuldig plädiert Trump war dort
Mitte August wegen seiner Versuche
angeklagt worden den Ausgang der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 in Georgia
nachträglich zu beeinflussen
unterdessen wurde heute in Zusammenhang
mit der Erstürmung des Kapitols im
Januar 2021 ein Urteil gefällt ein
ehemaliger Anführer der rechtsradikalen
proud Boys wurde wegen seiner
Beteiligung daran zu 17 Jahren Haft
verurteilt
der ukrainische Außenminister Kollege
hat die Bundesregierung erneut
aufgerufen Taurus Marschflugkörper im
Verteidigungskrieg gegen Russland zu
liefern es gäbe kein einziges Objektives
Argument gegen diese Entscheidung sagte
er beim EU-Außenminister Treffen in
Toledo die Minister zeigten sich laut
dem EU-Außenbeauftragten Borell zu dem
bereit Sanktionen gegen die Militär
Machthaber in Niger nach dem Putsch vor
gut einem Monat zu verhängen
ja wir bleiben noch Momente in dieser
Gegend der Welt Afrika im Umbruch mit
enormen Folgen für die Menschen dort es
ist nicht ganz leicht den Überblick zu
behalten eine Karte hilft immer die
meisten Länder liegen in der Sahelzone
Mali Burkina
Sudan und jetzt gerade erst Gabun
überall haben Militärs in den letzten
Jahren die Macht ergriffen überall
regieren projesten und jeder geglückte
Kuh scheint das Risiko zu er Höhen dass
es so weitergeht Europa wirkt ratlos die
eigene afrika-strategie die auch eine
Strategie gegen Fluchtursachen und
Terrorismus sein sollte liegt in
Trümmern und die einfachen Menschen in
der Region leiden im Sudan macht der
Machtkampf zwischen Armee und Miliz von
niemandem Halt mit verheerenden Folgen
für alle die zwischen die Fronten
geraten
unterwegs in cartou fast täglich kommt
es zu Explosionen und heftigen Straßen
kämpfen hier kämpft die sudanesische
Armee unter dem Präsident Burhan gegen
seinen einstigen Stellvertreter genannt
hameti und dessen Rapper Support forces
die haben seit April die Hauptstadt
besetzt bewiesene tote Körper sollen
überall in der Stadt offen rumliegen es
gibt kaum Strom kein Internet mehr die
Einwohner abgeschnitten von der
Außenwelt
hört auf mit dem Krieg Burhan hamiti
Gott soll Frieden zwischen euch bringen
der Krieg zerstört uns alle
was passiert wenn man zwischen die
Fronten gerät das hat Hagar erlebt Hager
hier gefesselt im Blau verhaftet von den
Rapper Support forces die ihm vorwerfen
die Armee zu unterstützen im
ZDF-Interview erzählt er von
stundenlanger Folter
sie kam mit Stromkabeln und Vorhang
Stangen damit schlugen sie uns während
sie das Kommando gaben Aufstehen
die Vereinten Nationen werfen den Rapper
Support
Gewalt dazu Vergewaltigung und sexuelle
Sklaverei von Frauen und Mädchen in mehr
als 100 Fällen vor wir treffen eine von
ihnen
die Erinnerung ist unerträglich drei
Soldaten sollen sie gleichzeitig
missbraucht haben
mein Mann seine Schwestern und die
Schwiegermutter waren dabei die Nachbarn
sie waren alle dabei
doch weil Vergewaltigung im Sudan
alsander angesehen wird hat der Ehemann
seine Frau und die drei Kinder verstoßen
sie ist nun alleine auf der Flucht und
vergeblich auf der Suche nach
medizinischer Versorgung ein Großteil
der Krankenhäuser geschlossen die
wenigen die noch geöffnet sind völlig
überlastet sogar die Betten müssen sich
geteilt werden
die meisten Patienten sterben weil der
Strom immer wieder ausfällt die anderen
weil wir sie nicht versorgen können
so droht Hunderttausenden Kindern im
Land der Hungertod eine von ihnen ist
Omnia seit 20 Tagen wartet die
dreieinhalbjährige in dem Krankenhaus
auf Behandlung doch die bleibt bisher
aus
wir wollen dass unsere Kinder ganz
normal aufwachsen können aber die
Zukunft unserer Kinder ist zerstört
im Sudan spitzt sich die humanitäre
Situation immer mehr zu vier Monate nach
Beginn der Kämpfe sind laut UN 4,3
[Musik]
ja was ist zu tun angesichts dieser
verheerenden Situation die wir da gerade
gesehen haben Gunnar Krüger beobachtet
die EU-Außenminister auf ihrer Konferenz
in Toledo Spanien Gunnar guten Abend die
salzzone steht da explizit auf der
Tagesordnung und zwar ganz oben es wird
aber als ob die Menschen im Sudan von
der Weltpolitik vergessen wurden
ja das stand ganz oben auf der
Tagesordnung und es ist sich ja auch
nicht so dass die Außenminister diese
Region vergessen hätten aber gleich
mehrere mussten heute ganz schonungslos
eingestehen Europa hat in der Region
viel weniger zu sagen als es das bislang
von sich selbst geglaubt hat und sie
machen das Fest ganz konkret nicht an
Sudan sondern am Land Niger auch dort
gab es einen Militärputsch da hat man
sich nun geeinigt auf Sanktionen gegen
die Militär unter die EU steckt
eigentlich in so einem doppelten Dilemma
sie ähm sie kann das Geld das sie hat
nur für Sicherheit nur einmal ausgeben
und sie muss aufpassen dass sie es nicht
den falschen gibt und das wird ein Niger
noch mal deutlich 40 Millionen Euro hat
dieses Land ein Militärhilfe erst im
März bekommen und diese 40 Millionen
Euro gegen eben genau an das Militär das
am Ende nun den Putsch gemacht hat und
die Demokratie in dem Land abgeschafft
hat und dieses Geld diese 40 Millionen
die kam auch noch aus dem gleichen Fonds
aus dem die EU auch Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine organisiert und da wird noch mal
deutlich wo der Fokus liegt einmal sind
es Millionen einmal sind es Milliarden
und wenn es jetzt einen eigenen Fonds
für die Ukraine geben soll mit 20
Milliarden Euro dann zeigt das eben auf
der einen Seite wo das wo der Fokus
liegt das zeigt aber auf der anderen
Seite eben auch ganz deutlich wenn wir
in diese beiden Posten trennt wie viel
die EU dann noch für andere Weltregionen
und ihre Sicherheit übrig hat
ja interessante Relation herzlichen Dank
Krüger war das live aus Toledo
und hier bei uns noch mal Johanna genau
ein Jahr ist es her das Russland den
Gashahn zugedreht hat was folgte war ein
rasanter Anstieg der Gaspreise ein
Bangen darum ob wir im Winter frieren
müssen und Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
um auf unterschiedlichsten Ebenen
gegenzusteuern Frank Wiedmann jetzt nach
einem Jahr wie erfolgreich war das wo
stehen wir jetzt und was könnte uns im
kommenden Winter erwarten im Großen und
Ganzen haben die Maßnahmen gewirkt wenn
wir da beispielsweise an die
entsprechende Preisbremse für Gas denken
wo der Staat gesagt hat für 80% des
vorjahresverbrauchs wird der Preis
gedeckelt trotzdem hat das zunächst
nichts daran geändert dass der
durchschnittliche Geist Preis für
Haushalte im vergangenen September ein
Allzeithoch erreichte zeitweise bei fast
22 Cent die Kilowattstunde notierte
derzeit liegt aber gut 12 Cent was man
in Anbetracht der Umstände als Erfolg
werden kann aber eben nicht zwischen 6
und 7 Cent wie noch vor dem Ukraine
kriegt immer vielen dank eines milden
Winters und guter Versorgungslage gehen
die Fachleute davon aus dass das jetzige
Preisniveau also von rund 12 Cent pro
Einheit auch über diesen Winter gehalten
werden kann es gab aber auch Profiteure
der Energiekrise wer war das zum
Beispiel naja internationale Konzerne
die Öl- und Gas fördern die konnten aus
der Situation Kapital schlagen also
Unternehmen wie BP Shell oder Exon dann
die Lieferländer die als Ersatz
eingesprungen sind und auch für die
kommenden Jahre gut dotierte Verträge
mit der Bundesrepublik abgeschlossen
haben wie Katha z.B
Reedereien die Flüssigkeit Schiffe
besitzen die nach wie vor knapp und
daher begehrt sind und natürlich
Heizungsbauer oder Elektriker die gerade
vom Run auf Solaranlagen oder
Wärmepumpen profitieren vielen Dank für
diese Einordnungen
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen in Deutschland
ist im August stärker gestiegen als
üblich Hauptgründe dafür sind laut der
Chefin der Arbeitsagentur Nahles die
schwache Konjunktur und die Sommerpause
im August waren demnach zwei Millionen
000 Menschen ohne Job das sind 79.000
mehr als im Juli und 148
000 mehr als immer August das
vergangenen Jahres die Arbeitslosenquote
stieg auf 5,8%
der Tropensturm ideellia hat im Südosten
der USA massive Überschwemmungen und
Schäden verursacht im US-Bundesstaat
Florida begannen Anwohner mit den
Aufräumarbeiten mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 200
Kilometer pro Stunde war er am Mittwoch
auf die Ostküste getroffen flutete
Straßen zerstörte Häuser und zog dann
weiter nach Georgia und South Carolina
der Hurrikan wurde mittlerweile zum
Tropensturm abgeschwächt
bald geht's wieder los mit der Champions
League auch für deutsche Clubs sind
dabei und seit heute steht fest auf wen
sie treffen werden Bayern München
bekommt es etwa mit Manchester United zu
tun Neuling Union Berlin trifft unter
anderem auf SSC Neapel und Real Madrid
Borussia Dortmund spielt gegen Paris St
Germain AC Mailand und Newcastle United
und RB Leipzig trifft unter anderem auf
Titelverteidiger Manchester City los
geht's am 19 September
Paris ist Eiffelturm und Louvre lange
Menüs und roter Wein romantiko Abende an
der Sand Paris ist Liebe ein Traum ein
Klischee und alles gleichzeitig bei
allen die da waren läuft sofort ein Film
ab im Kopf bei allen die noch nie da
waren läuft er möglicherweise noch
intensiver zu Paris gehören aber auch
und gerade die vielen Details am Rande
die ist hier gibt und nirgendwo anders
das darf sich nicht ändern und deshalb
berichtet unser Mann in Paris jetzt über
eine Institution unter Druck Thomas
Walde
es sind Kisten voller Geschichten und
voller Geschichte Boxen voller Bücher
wenn Jerome Calli an der sensern den
Laden aufmacht dann bietet er vor allem
klassische französische Literatur an
doch neuerdings macht ein anderes
Schriftstück im Gedanken ein Brief von
der Pariser Präfektur wir sollen in
sechs Tagen 600 Kisten abbauen das ist
nicht realistisch es sei denn sie machen
ein Massaker sie zerstören 400 500 die
es gibt
600 Kisten sollen aus dem Weg geräumt
werden wenn die Olympischen Spiele 2024
kommen die öffnungsfeier soll ein
Highlight werden nicht im Stadion
sondern auf der Sense der stören die
Kisten Sicherheitsgefahr sie müssen für
einige Wochen umziehen die burkinist
sind empört darunter die deutsche ihres
Menschen
dann gibt es auch buchkissen die sind
schon fast 80 Jahre immer auf dem
gleichen Standort die wurden quasi noch
nie bewegt sie müssen sich vorstellen
das sind ganz spezielle Bauten zum Teil
mit schiffsholz galvanisiert mit
speziellen Lack drüber wenn man die nur
einmal kurz verrückt dann bricht oft
schon was auseinander ich habe das bei
meinem Umzug gesehen ich musste die hier
auch hierher bringen und danach
aufwendig wieder sanieren Napoleon der
dritte erlaubte die Kisten sie machen
einen Teil des Charmes von Paris aus
sagen nicht nur die burkinist ein
Ausweichort den die Präfektur vorschlägt
verletzt ihren Stolz dann sind es
einfach Tische und da liegt irgendwas
drauf das ist genauso wenn ich auch
irgendwelche Gurken oder Tomaten
verkaufen würde und das möchte ich nicht
die burkinist nehmen das
Sicherheitsargument durchaus ernst und
schlagen eine Alternative vor
sie können auf Sprengstoff kontrollieren
eine Woche vor der Eröffnungsfeier mit
ihren Hunden gucken dass alles okay ist
dann schließt und versiegelt man die
Kisten und nach der Eröffnungsfeier
öffnen wir sie ganz normal so bleiben
sie unbeschädigt doch die Präfektur sagt
die Verlegung sei unausweichlich ein
Interview wollte sie uns nicht geben so
bleibt die Frage unbeantwortet ob die
Kisten nicht auch stören weil sie die
Sicht nehmen für Menschen die bis zu
2.700 € zahlen sollen für Karten zur
Eröffnungsfeier der Olympischen Spiele
von Paris
zurück aus der Stadt des Lichts und der
Liebe nach Deutschland Deutschland
abgehängt warum wächst die Wirtschaft
nicht fragt Maybrit Illner gleich Ihre
Gäste darunter ein Däne der jetzt
Wirtschaftsminister in
Schleswig-Holstein ist und seine eigenen
Ideen hat wie es hier bei uns vorangehen
könnte
und gegen 0.30 gibt es dann unser heute
journal Update mit Christopher Wehrmann
angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend das Tief heißt Günther und
dieses Tief Günther bringt uns schon
heute Nacht eine Warmfront die zieht
morgen langsam weiter nordwärts und dann
wird es bei uns auch tatsächlich wärmer
die Regenfälle setzen schon heute Nacht
im Südwesten ein hier im Nordosten gibt
es noch einige Regenschauer dazwischen
ist es trocken zum Teil auch mal klar
und dann bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken im Emsland oder auch
in der Lüneburger Heide bis 8 Grad sonst
liegen die Tiefstwerte meist knapp über
10 Grad am mildesten bleibt es am
Oberrhein und morgen erwarten uns
Höchsttemperaturen um 20 Grad am
Oberrhein wird es mit 26 Grad schon
sommerlich warm und morgen geht's vor
allen Dingen in Süddeutschland am
Nachmittag viel Sonnenschein die
Warmfront macht sich über der Mitte
bemerkbar da Schütte des kräftig da sind
auch Gewitter dabei freuen hier sieht's
dagegen an der Nordseeküste aus und dann
wird es von Tag zu Tag weniger Regen
geben und mehr Sonnenschein bei 20 bis
29 Grad das Mittelmeer ist ja zurzeit
ganz besonders warm besonders zentral
und restliche Mittelmeer mit 28 bis 30
Grad und das hat auch Auswirkungen auf
unser Wetter schauen wir uns die
Entwicklung der nächsten Woche an am
Sonntag bereits liegt ja ein kräftiges
Hoch über Mitteleuropa das schleusst die
Regengebiete um sich herum über
Nordeuropa und über Westeuropa und zum
Ende der kommenden Woche könnte sich
hier ein medican über dem zentralen
Mittelmeer bilden also eine Hurrikan
ähnliche Struktur das behalten wir
natürlich für Sie im Auge vielleicht
kommt es ja auch gar nicht dazu guten
Abend